Not every sentient anomaly the SCP Foundation
contains is a monstrosity hell-bent on destroying
the world, or a dangerous apex predator with
a taste for D-Class.
In fact, most aren’t.
Most sentient anomalies are perfectly docile,
even polite!
They range from helpful talking animals to
self-aware AI to former Foundation personnel
themselves.
There’s little need for these low-security
anomalies to be treated with the same paranoid
caution reserved for anomalies like SCP-939
and SCP-049, and for some of them the Foundation
can even help them out a little bit.
One of these anomalies is SCP-4149.
At a cursory glance, SCP-4149 seems to be
some sort of standard anomalous location,
not at all uncommon for the Foundation to
deal with.
Just stick a lock on it and call it a day,
right?
But the containment procedures tell a different
story.
MTF personnel are ordered to act like they
are visitors of an art gallery when inside
SCP-4149.
Not just that, but any “character breaks”
have to be played off like live theater.
What kind of strange anomaly requires hardened
agents and researchers to act like performance
artists?
Let’s go back to when the Foundation first
discovered SCP-4149.
It was 2007 in Chicago, and Foundation agents
across the city were staking out art galleries,
painting exhibitions, museums, and other fine
art repositories.
It wasn’t some wild goose chase to find
a painting-based anomaly like SCP-1155 or
SCP-3864, but instead a concerted operation
to root out anomalies and people associated
with the notorious Group of Interest: Are
We Cool Yet?
Don’t let Are We Cool Yet?’s name fool
you.
The Foundation has a long and storied history
with this group of subversive, nonconformist
artists that sprang up after World War 2.
They’ve changed over the years in political
attitudes and direction, but one thing remains
consistent: they make anomalous art.
And not just anomalous art - dangerously anomalous
art.
Paintings that drive people to madness, sculptures
that kill the viewers (sound familiar?), and
installations that result in dozens of casualties.
These anomalous art-terrorists are extremely
dangerous, and no one knows that better than
the Foundation.
Chicago, being known for its art, is one of
their favorite haunts.
So when the Foundation launched a stakeout
operation tracking known Are We Cool Yet?
members, they knew they’d find something
eventually.
That happened in June, when two Foundation
agents tailing a group of Are We Cool Yet?
Members saw them moving a number of paintings
out of a truck and into what seemed to be
a regular condominium.
The agents, excited to finally get a lead,
jumped out of the car and quietly followed
after them, right into the door of the building.
They rushed in with their guns to find…
nothing.
But on the second floor, things were more
interesting.
One of the Are We Cool Yet members was laying
on the ground, writhing in pain and covering
his face.
Upon being poked by one of the agents, he
lowered his hands, revealing a gory sight.
The man’s face was warped like a Picasso
painting.
His nose was on his forehead, his mouth was
slanted all the way to the left of his face
and his eyes were on his tongue.
He cries that the gallery did this to him,
and that his friend ran in.
The agents turn into the bedroom.
Instead of a wall and window, a large hallway
leading into a space that doesn’t exist
outside the building is present: SCP-4149.
The last things the agents see before calling
for backup: another Are We Cool Yet member
shaking hands with what appears to be a gigantic
sloth in a three-piece suit.
By the time MTF arrived with special anti-cognitohazard
gear, they were all ready to enter SCP-4149.
The four man team enters, rounding a corner
into what appears to be a makeshift art gallery
filled with anthropomorphic animals - lizards
in loungewear, birds in fancy dresses, and
the large sloth in a suit the agents had seen.
Along the walls are paintings and artworks
blurred by the agent's special eyewear.
It doesn’t take long before the team are
noticed by the animals, SCP-4149 instances,
who start criticizing their acting - in English,
to the MTF’s surprise.
The heavily-armed men start hearing complaints
and incompetent social commentary about their
lack of subtlety from a growing crowd of clothed
giant animals.
Confused, they’re eventually rescued by
the sloth, who plays off their strange arrival
as a performance piece gone awry and dismisses
the crowd to other art pieces.
After very slowly dragging them into a corner,
the besuited sloth politely introduces himself
as Professor Xorkanoff, the owner of this
art gallery.
He claims to be a “man” of culture, an
enjoyer of fine art who found he could only
truly operate his gallery how he wanted free
of the bounds of any one world.
In fact, the entirety of SCP-4149 exists in
its own pocket dimension.
Upon being asked, he explains that the Are
We Cool Yet member was trying to sell him
some work, but it wasn’t refined enough
for the Professor’s tastes.
But the artist seems to have run off to another
planet to train, specifically one lacking
an atmosphere.
The Professor agrees to be designated as SCP-4149-2
and undergo interviewing to help the Foundation
understand what the situation surrounding
his gallery is, which is where the Foundation
finds most of their information for the anomaly’s
description.
SCP-4149 is what’s known as an extradimensional
space - a location that doesn’t quite exist
in any one reality, but by itself in a pocket
dimension.
It’s accessible through the hallway in the
apartment building, which the Foundation has
bought and slated for demolition.
Inside SCP-4149, one can access a large warehouse
serving as a gallery, containing upwards of
70 different art pieces, ranging from fancy
oil paintings to contemporary sculptures and
modern art.
Almost all of them are cognitohazardous in
one way or another - extremely dangerous to
the untrained human mind.
The gallery itself seems to be populated by
a wide variety of entities, not just the finely-dressed
animals that caught the MTF off guard.
They claim to come from all the various neighboring
universes and realities that SCP-4149 borders,
and seem to be fine looking at all of the
art pieces.
And of course, the proprietor of the establishment:
SCP-4149-2, Professor Xorkanoff.
Two meters tall, dressed in a nice waistcoat
and tweed jacket.
Foundation agents all describe him as friendly
and polite to a fault - even if he is a giant
sloth.
Unfortunately, that means everything he says
or does is at a snail’s pace - or more accurately,
a sloth’s pace.
But he usually spends his time plodding between
the various art pieces and explaining or discussing
them with the guests as curator of the gallery.
Where the Professor gets the artworks isn’t
quite clear, nor is how.
He says he can travel through universes and
worlds to some degree, but this is unconfirmed
– for now, all the Foundation knows is that
sometimes the works in SCP-4149 just suddenly
seem to cycle out with new attractions.
The gallery isn’t a perfect socializing
space, though.
The entry that exists in the apartment building
is a design flaw, a construction error - but
not one that can be easily fixed without tearing
the entire place down and starting again,
something the Professor has sounded very upset
at, when someone deciphered his glacial yelling.
SCP-4149 is friendly to Foundation interests,
though.
The Professor doesn’t want uninvited guests
to know about his gallery any more than the
Foundation does.
To that end, he’s cut a deal: so long as
SCP-4149-2 submits to background interviews
and SCP-4149 is carefully kept under containment,
SCP-4149-2 will be permitted to keep operating
his gallery and the Foundation will protect
it against hostile intruders.
What intruders, you ask?
Well, you’ll have to look to the interviews
for that.
The main interview is conducted by a D-class,
through an earpiece.
The giant sloth’s statements have to be
sped up multiple times to be understandable
on the recording.
It starts off simple - Xorkanoff is the best
human approximation to the Professor’s real
name.
Him coming from another world, presumably
one inhabited by other sloths, his name wasn’t
designed to be spoken by simple humans.
But he explains: the universe that SCP-4149
exists in is a shell, a universe that has
undergone heat death and become completely
empty before being compacted into just enough
space to build SCP-4149.
The Professor, having some ability to pop
from universe to universe, decided to make
this place his home and host to his love of
art and expression.
He seems reluctant to talk about his original
home, though, until directly asked by the
D-class.
Then he explains.
He was a man in well-standing in his home
universe, on a world inhabited by creatures
similar to himself.
He enjoyed all the fruits of society: culture,
music, social occurrences - and yes, art.
Unfortunately, the rest of his society didn’t
share his views on art.
They considered it not only a waste of time
- but an insult, an offensive level of arrogance.
Being a highly technological society, they
thought art and humanities were inappropriate
expressions of emotion.
But from the Professor’s point of view,
all this had done was create a deeply unhappy,
deeply uneducated society.
His private art collection in his manor was
a closely-guarded secret.
But eventually, the secret got out.
His name was spat out as a cultural extremist,
a subversive nonconformist who was giving
dangerous ideas to the next generation.
A mob formed, and did what mobs do best: they
chased him from his home at night and burned
his collection.
Barely escaping with his life and the few
pieces of art he could grab, the Professor
swore to rebuild his collection for the joy
of all.
As the interview continues, the D-class reveals
he is blind - that’s how he’s avoided
being driven insane by any of the many cognitohazardous
art pieces.
The Professor hasn’t heard of blindness
before, but sympathizes.
Eventually, things settle into a familiar
rhythm.
Professor Xorkanoff continues to operate his
gallery for the pleasure of all his visitors,
and the Foundation need only station one armed
guard in the apartment instead of spending
time, money, and effort forcing everyone into
inconvenient containment in the middle of
a crowded city.
But just a few short months later, the Foundation
receives a call from the agent on duty, requesting
backup.
Once again, the MTF arrived on the scene,
kitted out for cognitohazards.
They enter into SCP-4149, heavily armed and
armored.
This time, they find something much more surprising
and dangerous than an art exhibition.
The guests are lurking around the edges of
the walls, but the Professor is in the middle
of the floor, arguing extremely slowly with
two more giant sloths.
They’re dressed in tactical combat gear
and holding what looks to be guns.
Their yelling, sped up, is made clear: the
newcomers are berating the Professor for expressing
his art and for running from something called
the ‘Xenarthra Council’.
When they finally notice the presence of the
MTF, they scoff and gradually raise their
weapons, telling the MTF to leave while they
still have the chance.
But while one of them is busy yelling at the
sloths to drop their weapons, another one
of the troops simply walks over and pulls
the guns out of the clawed paws of the sloths:
“They’re sloths, man.”
By the time they slowly realize their weapons
are no longer in their hands, the sloths panic
at the thought of these strange furless creatures
moving so many times faster than they ever
thought possible.
Just before they’re handcuffed, the pair
disappear in a burst of green light - and
at this, all the guests burst into applause.
This conflict, this emotion, this humour:
this is the performance they were waiting
for the whole time!
Now Check out Killer Living Graffiti SCP-1155
- Predatory Street Art or SCP-683 - Refrigerator
Art for more art-related anomalies that will
blow your mind!